[Music]
hi you look so gorgeous look at you the
Grammys tonight tell me a little bit
about the album cover I have an album
coming out in the next couple of months
my single be out in a few weeks
been working on it for almost three
years now so I'm very excited where
everyone to get to hear it finally kitty
I also noticed something else you were
excited about you met Celine Dion come
on how crazy is it okay so she was
getting out of a car just now and I was
literally just alone standing outside of
the hotel and I was like I'm not gonna
fangirl out because I get it it's a big
day today so I just stood there and she
looked at me she goes you look beautiful
and then of course I was like I'm the
biggest fan and she should be like and
she's amazing so I just I take it as a
sign from God that it's gonna be a good
day but that's like the Grammys in a
nutshell isn't it and you show up here
for your own exciting things but at the
same time you kind of fan him out on
everybody else it's really an amazing
evening I'm such a fan of music
especially the nominees this year I was
at Clive Davis's event last night I got
to see chance the rapper perform
Jennifer Hudson Sonne amazing people and
I can't wait to see all the performances
tonight
you